neonapolis has a new attraction that is
bringing movie magic to las vegas jc is
live at the movie prop experience with
more hi jc
hey jillian i apologize in advance i'm
going to say wow a lot during this
segment because this is unbelievable
first off wolverine's claws this is
incredible and this is doug hayla the
general manager are these the actual
views in the movie claws they were used
by hugh jackman in x-men origins wow
there's the first whale this stuff is
unbelievable you have quite the
collection here let's kind of walk and
talk about some of the stuff that we're
looking at i recognize that one from is
empire strikes back it is it's han solo
and carbonite what are some of these
costumes that you guys have here in
front of us well here's a classic one
from buck rogers it's the hawk
that's from around the 70s and and where
did you guys get these items because
that's a classic piece from the 70s
where did you guys get these items well
a lot of this stuff is curated by a
place called hero prop
heroprop.com has supplied us with a
great collection here henry come back up
here because i'm gonna show you some of
this over here uh you fans of the
x-files you'd recognize this from the
television show the x-files and you were
telling me too that you guys have so
much stuff that you're gonna be changing
stuff out as the weeks and months go on
and we want to change as much as we can
and think new things are always coming
in
um is that actually iron man's hand it
sure is whoa
what i love about it down here it's easy
to get to but second there's so many
instagram worthy spots that we see sure
tell us what are we looking at here this
is a sentinel the art department created
this little miniature so they can
uh visualize what they wanted out of
this out of these drawings so that's an
actual art department piece i'll be
honest i'm kind of nervous holding the
actual claws from the x-men movie
because this is movie history right here
yeah just keep a fist keep it it'll be
fine i'm starting to get sweaty palms
right now and when you come inside you
have to look up henry flip around and
look up what's where's this airplane
from that is from memphis bell and it's
a believe it or not it's a miniature of
the actual memphis bell actually that's
from the pink lady and it's been
stickered with mother and country
which wasn't the memphis bell but it was
a the accompanying b17 okay perfect spin
around we have about 30 seconds and i
recognize some of these from
predator versus alien and then here's an
alien queen up here this is our she's
the big queen in vegas now
um vegas has a new queen it's not since
adele's residency is taking place this
is the new queen here in town guys
coming up we have stuff from batman
we've got stuff from gremlins we have
all kinds of cool movie props to show
you there's so much more coming up here
on las vegas now and we will be
right back